Hey youtubers it’s charlie and this week
on arrow it’s christmas and everyone deserves
a present.
We find out who the real big bad is this season
and barry allen became the flash.
So because this was the mid season finale
arrow won’t be back for 5 weeks, but I’ll
be doing bonus videos between now and then,
so subscribe to get everything.
I’ll also be doing flash videos too.
Since there were so many big payoffs let’s
do our top 10 moments and then I’ll do my
review.
Number 10 - Star Labs.
the particle accelerator malfunctions, and
given the riots going on when it was working
it’s unlikely that they continue with that
line of technology.
Leaving them free to experiment more with
other things like cyborgs.
Star Labs is in central city, so any future
superheroes to come from it will most likely
be featured on the flash show first, not on
arrow.
9 Solomon Grundy poem.
A lot of you caught the cyrus gold solomon
grundy nod last week.
This week they even read the poem out loud.
Twice.
Solomon Grundy, Born on a Monday, Christened
on a Tuesday, Married on a wednesday, took
ill on Thursday, grew worse on Friday, died
on saturday, buried on sunday, that was the
end.
of solomon grundy.
By the way, he is definitely not dead, despite
what oliver thinks.
8 ballicity - Barry let’s felicity know
that if she’s ever wants to go on a date,
he’ll never be late.
A nice nod to the flash and it teases that
they’ll be dating in the future.
Since grant gustin isn’t going to guest
star on arrow every week as the flash, oliver
and diggle will probably just tease felicity
about her and barry every once in a while.
The other funny thing about barry is that
he’s not just jealous of oliver for getting
to be with felicity all the time, he’s jealous
of felicity for getting to be around the arrow
all the time.
Man crush red alert.
7 Slade’s New Powers - Slade wakes up on
the sub and he’s pissed.
He doesn’t even realize he has super powers
until he starts snapping guns in half like
they’re pencils and punching holes in guys
chests.
Easily one of the best revenge moments of
the season so far.
6 You should look into compressible micro
fabric.
Barry totally teases not only oliver’s green
arrow mask, but his flash suit.
If anyone is wondering, the creators have
said that his flash outfit won’t be exactly
like the comics.
But it will probably be something plain looking
made out of compressible micro fabric.
Barry also has a keen eye for use of color.
He grills oliver on his choice of green.
This attention to color detail is important
later.
5 Good thing you have a rat problem.
Barry wakes oliver up with poison.
Amazing.
It was funny and a little terrifying in the
same moment.
Good to know that rat poison works as a blood
thinner.
But i’d check with your doctor before trying
it at home.
4 barry left a present for you.
Barry leaves oliver his green arrow mask and
wraps it in newspaper with a red flash on
the corner.
Just more teasing, but oliver is now one step
closer to taking the green arrow name.
It will happen this season, but first he has
to battle slade and brother blood to prove
he’s a true hero.
3 Roy has powers.
If it wasn’t clear from this episode, then
the teaser for the next episode made it plain
as day.
Roy has all the same powers solomon grundy
and slade have.
Super strength, super speed, super durability.
A lot of you have been wondering if he’s
going to become speedy.
Here’s how it happened in the comic books,
first he was green arrow’s sidekick and
was called speedy, then he joined teen titans
and became arsenal, then he joined the justice
league and became red arrow.
Because they used the red arrows in previous
episodes, I’m thinking that they’ll just
skip to roy calling himself an version of
the red arrow.
Like Red.
Oliver, felicity and diggle will probably
tease him by calling him speedy though.
He’ll spend the rest of this season learning
to control his powers.
As seen in the new teaser.
2 Slade is the new big bad.
So not only is slade still alive, he’s also
the one behind brother blood.
The creators said in a recent interview that
after slade found shado dead and vowed revenge,
things did not get better between him and
oliver.
Oliver said that he killed everyone that took
the serum on the island.
so at some point he probably tried to kill
slade and believed him dead.
But because he’s super now, he has super
healing powers.
And a rad silver highlight with an eyepatch.
So close to classic deathstroke, so awesome.
and my number 1 moment.
barry allen becomes the flash.
As predicted Barry was infused with the speedforce.
It was a nice nod to the classic barry allen
flash story happening in his lab.
If you were confused, the particle accelerator
tore a hole in space time and the lightning
that struck him was the speed force, not just
regular lightning.
The yellow and red liquids rising up were
a nice visual reference to what’s coming.
The creators have said that he won’t be
wearing red spandex, but remember how barry
was talking to oliver about compression fabric.
And remember what a big deal color is for
him.
But let me know what your favorite moment
was, was it watching barry become the flash,
was it seeing slade again?
Like I said, i’ll be doing regular arrow
and flash bonus vids during the break.
be sure to subscribe to get them.
be sure to let me know what you want me to
include in them.
Right now click here to watch last week’s
arrow video and click here for my breakdown
of the doctor who christmas special.
Thanks for watching, high fives.
see you guys tomorrow!